it is now down to what we are calling
here at channel 8 the spicy 16. it is in
our local pizza brackets you can see the
bracket there it's naked city lucinos
giordano's and
dom demarcos well tell us about uh your
pizza you mentioned you're in the final
four dom demarco is certainly well known
here in the valley here's one of our
pizzas don demarco's it's all about
quality is there a secret ingredient or
way you make it what what makes it so
special my father a lot you know he came
over from italy came with that
experience he's a blessing to me and
that's really the secret we use some of
the most precious tomatoes and
everything here are the final four naked
city giordano's lucinos and dom demarcos
so this is dom demarco's which one is
that lucino casino
and the winner is
dumb demarcos we're very passionate
about everything we do here at dom de
marcos and
we love food
so we make it like we're making it for
us we had our own sample it was
delicious but like i said no such thing
as bad pizza this one was just extra
yummy